welcome to this video MGB 223 from
Canada okay a French I want to vary a
bit let's see okay I have a pretty rare
line in the vanilla that I sometimes
play with them with an early b6 and like
to try that out a 3 takes and b6 kind of
a specialty that are sometimes employ
hmmm what I wonder is why doesn't my
flick us not showing any more I mean
it's not really important but hmm i
don't know why that is okay so he's
allowing me this Bishop trade let's get
this it should have taken on c3 of
course it's do better stupid yeah that
was stupid so sure it's given him the
the double pawns okay let's take one c3
it's not great here should have done
that before when he actually was forced
to take with the pawn why is he even
seeing wow what okay just voluntarily it
went for this this is kind of strange
hmm a bit surprised about all that this
looks like a very decent position now I
think now we have traded some some
pieces which is quite helpful my
somewhat weakened position yeah with
dark squares in a good week it's helpful
to trade some pieces to reduce any
attack and attacking potential okay now
is even trading Queens yeah both
captures do make some sense absolutely
difficult and shouldn't I didn't want to
spend all the time on it both are they
as mentioned both them did make quite
some sense I try to put some pressure on
the deep on with the way I play it
preventing Bishop and 95 what he did
with bishop d to prevent night a fire
for the moment but if I go night is
seven the pollen deform will be attacked
and now he has to I mean I don't know
see 395 is one thing yep here we go
and now put this on d5 yeah very nice
nice Knights the other one will count to
see fourth and here we go you can try to
trade it with 92 okay um let's activate
aha so maybe he wants to play King you
three FB 500gb we'll just keep the keep
tonight down i played this rather
quickly which is a good thing but i was
thinking hmm might be too was something
that i should have considered but he
really has the ugly move up t to mmm
ugly but effective yeah maybe 94 94 to
c5 know he's doing that that is
surprising this is just a very nice
endgame now it's a very important point
would be six I can use this be six
square to prepare the the doubling on be
aid
ciao is this a winning end game or not
yeah we going to find out because I will
I will go for it let's see a key is
probably that I have to make sure that
he's got more stuff on dark squares he
doesn't agree he just thinks it's all
great of it if it is on tax class ok
surprising but still difficult to to win
or at least let's say I don't see how I
wonder fc5 is animals try to trade takes
and then night over to c6 this kind of
things
it says the big fan that's nice okay
well c5 the idea is that I want to
weaken the support of the e5 the e5 pawn
so take so King takes King back know
that I'm not going to that that I'm not
believing really takes okay I have to do
this anyway ticks and now how how to do
that a4 or King here and night to be
five it's also quite good right that
this is good yeah this is good just for
see three kings you for invasion time
and then I take d floor jack and can pre
move that Jack bishop hangs has to move
and then I take T fourth and then this
is full-scale invasion on the light
squares I don't think that does this
Bishop against night end game this looks
very difficult very difficult to hold if
if possible at all ya ever cheeky five
now he might have king d3 and stuff so I
wonder what does the Knight b6 it's not
a good idea I can but I can I can
improve a little bit first I don't need
to do anything drastic I have the more
active position here so Knight to c6
synthesis of a good thing
check
yeah for once I was I was ahead on the
clock H Gerner was there in Santa last
last hoop yeah an interesting an
interesting hello endgame semi endgame
the light squared control was very nice
and one interesting point is really here
I thought that we Knight takes e4 is
giving black very one-sided game we're
really it's only a question if white can
who would or not a really expected night
thought about this one maybe or
potentially a Ford's also maybe a move
try to exploit this temporary issue in
coordination and it shouldn't be too bad
for what but I'm curious if this is
really losing or not if he takes my pawn
structure gets improved so this one here
here yeah I know we got this trade in
age five this is a thing important to
get this fixed on the on the dark
squares as much as possible he actually
put something more on the dark squares
this this looks and questionable I think
and now we got this yella this is lost i
think a three should should lose but I
wondered i'm not totally positive that
this is winning from luck not at all I
mean this is it is pretty substantial
yeah he's got all pawns on dark square
so it cannot be any good but can blegh
win very difficult the same
something like that I don't know I can I
can try I can try various things Knight
to c6 for example and take the weakness
but it's got Bishop f4 the computer does
not see a clear win it just gives black
some some advantage but not much maybe
maybe there is no in it's possible but
there are various ideas of course that
that that can be tried hmm maybe it can
hold I doubt it but maybe he can it's
not so easy to see a way forward now um
let's say stuff like that and then I can
go I can go 26 if I like this kind of
thing but how do I have wind from here I
mean how do I make any any sort of
headway the king is always near the pond
so I can night to be five or something
but he just drops back I don't know he
still has quite some defensive resources
here ok interesting game thanks for
watching